he affected 2.1 acres on his own land in
cleaning up what had been a terrible
disaster actually everybody had had kind
of abused that farm because it had been
leased by absentee farmers for many
years uh he took out he's an engineer
and so he designed a beautiful uh
channel through there to to make sure
that the water could flow reduce
sedimentation reduce any type of
chemication going into the bighorn river
and that sort of thing at one point by
moving 2.1 acres by affecting 2.1 acres
on his own property he was facing
penalties of 65 million dollars because
the epa claims that they can they can
impose penalties at that time of thirty
seven thousand five hundred dollars a
day
uh that has now gone up to fifty nine
thousand dollars a day
if you violate the clean water act so
what they do is they come into these
farmers or ranchers and they say you
violated the clean water act you're
facing penalties of 59 000 a day unless
you do exactly what we tell you to do
well obviously two days you're dead
broke so nobody can fight back against
them and that's the thing is that
congress never should have given that
kind of authority to a bureaucracy
because giving a bureaucracy that kind
of punishment authority they turn into
dictators and that's what they've done
so how do we scale some of that stuff
back because i think you're right most
people at this point
don't believe in the institutions they
feel something has gone horrifically
awry they feel like what comes out of dc
has nothing to do with their day-to-day
life regardless of what you think of the
events of january 6 specifically i've
just never met anyone in the last year
who's really walking around saying this
is the biggest issue of the day but
they're obsessed with this stuff to sort
of keep our eye off the ball i mean what
do you think from a constitutional
perspective a legal perspective like
what can we do actually to reverse the
machine a little bit and get things back
to the way the country was supposed to
be run well one of the things that i've
been doing since i made the decision to
run for this office is i have reached
out to a variety of congressional
representatives in washington dc to
start building those relationships and
the ally ships that i'm going to need to
be an effective congresswoman back there
and one of the things that i've talked
to them repeatedly about are what my
priorities are and my priorities are
taking power out of washington dc we
need to be working with our governors
our good and effective governors the rod
ron desantis's of the world
we need to be working with our good and
effective attorney generals and we need
to be doing what what was intended by by
our foundational documents and that is
there should be very little power in
washington dc so even congress we have
got to start divesting ourselves but
we've really got to be divesting uh the
the unelected bureaucrats of the power
that they have and that they have
amassed over the last 10 15 years i've
been traveling the country giving a
speech called regulation without
representation and i've been exposing
what has been happening with our
administrative state and that's
primarily what i've dealt with as a as a
trial attorney so i'm a trial attorney
i've represented a lot of landowners and
business owners against the epa u.s fish
and wildlife service u.s forest service
usda all of the all of the alphabet
agencies if you will
fighting to protect our private property
rights fighting against their incredible
government overreach attempting to take
control of our irrigation infrastructure
and those sorts of things i want to take
that expertise to washington dc work
with my fellow congressional
representatives and find ways to
substantially um impact the power and
reduce the power that these agencies
have over the citizens of this country
it was never intended to be that way in
addition to which there's just such an
enormous waste associated with it you
know the epa tens of thousands of
employees yet every single state has a
department of environmental quality why
do we have tens of thousands of
employees in the epa all of whom seem to
think that their job is to punish people
rather than working with our states uh
you know our state department of
environmental quality i get along great
with the deq here in wyoming i'll tell
you what the epa and i go head-to-head
and i've had to have trials against him
and beat the dog out of them in order to
keep them back from you know trying to
take control of my my clients properties
um but why would the epa be able to come
into a world in wyoming and and start
attempting to punish people for
straightening an irrigation ditch yet
that's what they do we need to expose it
we need to roll it back we need to bring
that power back to the states where it
belongs but it's congress that's going
to have to act to do it
yeah actually can you explain that sort
of thing a little bit further because i
think a lot of people they still hear
the epa the word protections in their
environment it sort of sounds right okay
they must be nice people doing these
things as you said there's now thousands
and thousands of people that are part of
this but can you give me an example of
what type of thing would be
happening in wyoming where you know
someone is living their life as they see
fit whatever water rights they have or
whatever other natural resource it is
and what the epa would want to do
why they would claim they would want to
do it and then what happens when you get
into a fight with them well i'll tell
you i'll give you one example of a case
that i handled up in northern wyoming
and it was outside of warland where i
was last week i represented a landowner
and he moved an irrigation ditch on his
property and the epa and i know it was a
test case they came in and claimed that
he violated the clean water act by doing
that because that irrigation ditch was a
quote navigable water of the united
states it wasn't it was an irrigation
ditch he had the right to to maintain it
and to move it and do what he did
it took us six years they filed the the
enforcement action against him in 2008
we finally had a two-week trial in 2014
i'm smart enough to know that you always
get a jury trial when you're going up
against the federal government for many
reasons but one is that the that a lot
of judges anymore are federal employees
i mean they are federal employees and
they think of themselves that way so uh
i had a jury and after a two-week jury
trial they came back and ruled in my
client's favor he affected 2.1 acres on
his own land
in cleaning up what had been a terrible
disaster actually everybody had had kind
of abused that farm because it had been
leased by absentee farmers for many
years uh he took out he's an engineer
and so he designed a beautiful uh
channel through there to to make sure
that the water could flow reduce
sedimentation reduce any type of
chemigation going into the bighorn river
and that sort of thing at one point by
moving 2.1 acres by affecting 2.1 acres
on his own property he was facing
penalties of 65 million dollars because
the epa claims that they can they can
impose penalties at that time of thirty
seven thousand five hundred dollars a
day
uh that has now gone up to fifty nine
thousand dollars a day
if you violate the clean water act so
what they do is they come into these
farmers or ranchers and they say you
violated the clean water act you're
facing penalties of 59 000 a day unless
you do exactly what we tell you to do
well obviously two days you're dead
broke so nobody can fight back against
them and that's the thing is that
congress never should have given that
kind of authority to a bureaucracy
because giving a bureaucracy that kind
of punishment authority they turn into
dictators and that's what they've done
so right now i'm handling a lawsuit i
don't know if you remember when the epa
blew out the gold king mine in
southwestern colorado and they turned
the animus river orange
uh it was in 2015. you can google it it
was one of the worst environmental
disasters in our country's history and
the epa did it
so they went in and without my client's
permission or knowledge they built a
water treatment facility on his property
they've operated it for six and a half
years and never paid him a dime in rent
it's an unconstitutional takings that's
the kind of abuse that the epa
visits upon our land owners every day
what the epa is trying to do is they'd
like to take control of all water
resources in this country but we know
what happens when the federal government
takes control of anything especially
when it is a resource such as water that
is absolutely necessary for life you
know what happens we're seeing it with
medical care they're saying okay you
don't get the vaccine we're going to
take away your job we're going to take
away your unemployment we're going to
take away your medical care that's
exactly what they're moving on and they
have been moving on with water this is
no longer any kind of a conspiracy idea
this is truly what the federal
government does one of the most horrific
things that happened in this country was
obamacare because that's when the
federal government decided that they
could control our decision making by
controlling our access to health care
and look at what they've done to us in
the last two years they want to do the
same thing with water if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell